here's another exciting new initiative
it's actually kind of working out that
we don't have an interview today because
there's so much that I have been waiting
to talk to the audience about and just
haven't had time you might remember that
a few months ago I told you that the
david pakman show had launched on a new
platform called steam it st double e MIT
and without getting super deep into the
nitty gritty steam it is a blockchain
based platform we were instead of our
content earning money through people
watching ads we earn money through
people up voting our content and this is
what our steam it presents looks like
we're showing the the television
audience right now which is it steam it
comm slash at David Pakman and the way
it works is the larger ones stake is on
the platform and that is measured by
something called steam power the more in
earnings that they can assign to content
they like when they up voted so let me
give you an example when I first signed
up on Steam it I had a brand new account
I had no stake in the platform so my
steam power was was zero when I would up
vote a piece of content I liked I would
be giving the Creator half a penny not a
lot of money right not gonna get you a
lot of bumper stickers with half a penny
but over time as I've gained more steam
power on the platform I now have about
5,200 steam power now when I up vote
someone else they get about a dollar and
fifty cents that is a major major
difference if you multiply that out over
thousands of users that becomes real
money so then the obvious question is
how does one accumulate steam power well
there's two ways by posting and by
curating other content and the thing I
like about the platform is that there's
no such thing as censorship or D
monetization because the content that
users upvote in proportion to their
steam power is what generates earnings
for content it's what gains visibility
and as you can imagine this has been
really big for us in the wake of
YouTube's the monetization ad pocalypse
so that's how it works right
I've told you all of that stuff before
several hundred of our viewers and
listeners have gone over to steam it and
they've started building up their
accounts the reason I'm bringing it up
today is that over the last four to six
weeks conservatives have started to sort
of overrun the steam it platform
partially because they've also been hit
to some degree by D monetization and
partially because they simply liked the
platform because who wouldn't it's a
great platform with no censorship at all
so it's been a couple of months since I
mentioned steam it to you but I am
asking for your help today we got onto
the steam it platform ahead of many of
these recent right-wingers that have
gone on so we sort of have a head start
but without your help we're gonna fall
behind there so my request is make an
account right go to steam it calm that's
st double e MIT create an account by
hitting the signup button that's in the
upper right of the page it does take a
few hours to a couple of days to get
your account approved just hit that just
bear that in mind when you go through
the signup process and once your account
is approved follow us we are at David
David Pakman on the steam blockchain and
if you want you can also set up an auto
voter for all of our posts there's
another website which works with the
steam platform called steam voter and
you can go there and actually configure
your account to automatically up vote
what we post now even if you don't
understand a word of what I'm talking
about
you can still contribute which is just
go and make the account and then up vote
anything that we post and this has been
a big big help to us over the last four
months and it's only going to get bigger
for us if and this is a big if we can
get more of our audience to help us out
to give you an example a post on steam
it that does really well has like two
hundred and fifty up votes okay if we
can get just one percent of our audience
to follow us on steam it and to upvote
our content we will by orders of
magnitude multiply what an average good
post is on that platform so there's a
huge opportunity I hope people will help
us and I'll keep you posted as far as
how's it going on upcoming programs